غالبًا ما يُطلق عليه
سرطان البروستاتا القاتل الصامت. يمكن أن ينمو ببطء على مدار
سنوات قبل اكتشافه. بشكل عام،
لن يعاني معظم الرجال من أي أعراض على الإطلاق
عندما يتم تشخيص إصابتهم
بسرطان البروستاتا لأول مرة، يقول الدكتور ويليام داي هت من
جمعية السرطان الأمريكية إنه
يمكن أن يكون هناك لون أحمر مرتبط بالبروستاتا  الأعلام
بما في ذلك صعوبة التبول
وزيارات الحمام المتعددة في منتصف
الليل ووجود دم في
البول في حين أن هذه الأعراض يمكن أن تكون أيضًا
شيئًا آخر غير السرطان، يقول إنه من
المهم رؤية الطبيب، فهو في الواقع
أكثر شيوعًا مع تقدمك في السن، فهو
أكثر شيوعًا  في السود أكثر من البيض وهو
أكثر شيوعًا إذا كان لديك
تاريخ عائلي أو طفرات جينية معينة.
عادة ما يتم اكتشاف سرطان البروستاتا
من خلال فحص دم بسيط ويمكن
تأكيده من خلال التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي بالموجات فوق الصوتية أو
فحص الخزعة. تختلف التوصيات
بناءً على المخاطر، أما أولئك الذين لديهم خطر متوسط ​​فهم
ينصحون  لبدء الفحص في سن 50.
يجب أن يبدأ الرجال الأكثر عرضة للخطر في
سن 40 و 35 تقريبًا، ويجب على الأشخاص الأكثر عرضة للخطر والذين لديهم
تاريخ عائلي قوي للمرض أن
يبدأوا مناقشات الفحص
في سن 40 تقريبًا. إذا اكتشفت
سرطان البروستاتا مبكرًا، فيمكن علاجه
بشكل فعال  حيث لا يعود
أو في كثير من الأحيان يمكننا مشاهدته
لسنوات وسنوات دون علاج
ثم نتدخل فقط عندما
يظهر السرطان علامة على أنه أصبح
أكثر عدوانية أو أنه بدأ في النمو من أجل
الصحة، أنا آندي غايثر